Hungary has vetoed a proposed 18 billion
Euro financial aid package from the EU
to Ukraine leaving the remaining
26-member Nations scrambling to find
ways to keep the cash flowing to Kiev
many of them believe Victor orban's
government is refusing to cooperate over
Ukraine because Brussels is withholding
billions of Euros waiting for Budapest
to implement rule of law reforms the
European commission has called for Unity
and speed
now both EU member Hungary and its
neighbor Serbia have been ambivalent in
their stance over Russia and moscow's
War on Ukraine speaking at a meeting
between EU leaders and nations in the
western Balkans hoping to join the block
the president of Kosovo didn't means her
words when it came to belgrade's dance
on one side you have countries that
fully align with the European Union and
on the other side you have countries
that fully align with Putin they should
not be treated the same whether you
stand with Ukraine today or you stand
with Russia should matter whether you
have adopted sanctions against Russia or
not should matter and these are signals
which the EU should send very very
clearly to all of the countries of the
western Balkans because standing at the
right side of history today is the least
that should be expected of us
anastasiophedic is an assistant
professor of Finance at Haas School of
Business at the University of California
Berkeley she's also a founding member of
the pressure group Economist for Ukraine
Ms fedig welcome Hungary vetoing aid for
Ukraine how much does that weaken the EU
stands vis-a-vis Russia
now of course hunger's actions are both
now and throughout the last nine months
have been problematic um Hungary has not
supported a Ukraine in the same way as
its um other EU partners and what we're
seeing is that hunger is actually using
it as a lever um to kind of extract what
it wants from the EU um of course on the
other hand it's also a lever that other
member states of the EU have um to get
hungry to conform um to what the broader
Union wants to do so it goes both ways
and the aid and that Hungary needs from
the EU is something that both Hungary is
demanding and kind of um use withholding
it to Ukraine as a way to get what they
want but it's also something on which
Hungary is ultimately dependent um so it
is a lever that allows the other
European States um to usually get
Hungary to go home so what does this
mean for the 26 EU countries that want
to see more money flowing to keep do
they just have to sit it out will Orban
eventually come around
no I don't think we have the luxury of
sitting um out anything when it comes to
Aid to Ukraine right now the situation
is very urgent um so we definitely do
need a speed in um in kind of
implementing any of these eight packages
so what we're seeing instead is that the
European commission is considering um
how else it can deliver that It
ultimately other member states are going
to be able to get money into Ukraine if
they want to get money into Ukraine
whether they do so in a Consolidated
matter with each other
um using kind of other mechanisms
including subsets of States uh pulling
together through enhanced cooperation or
if they do it individually and it's
unlikely but at the end of the day they
have these options
um so they can get that money to Ukraine
and um at the end of the day if they
want to they can also reduce then the
budget of the broader EU
um and kind of do things more
independently that is actually going to
be harmful for Hungary Hungary is
among the most dependent on EU budgets
so to kind of weaken the overall EU
budget relative to individual countries
budgets is not going to be in hungary's
best interests um so it is feasible that
Hungary will understand this and will
reverse
um this decision that it's showing right
now but even if it doesn't other member
states definitely have ways um to not
rely on Hungary to do something like
deliberate let's talk about Serbia how
can the EU increase pressure on
membership candidates to clearly side
with Ukraine
um yeah I I think uh watching um kind of
what what goes on with Hungary is
perhaps a way to do that um so kind of
the benefits that Hungary is drawing
from EU um membership
um as well as the expectations that that
sets on Hungary um to um kind of to
behave both um in with respect to uh
things like joint initiatives including
into Ukraine but also including domestic
things like corruption and rule of law
um I think other kind of hopeful members
are observing that and that definitely
gives them an indication of both the
expectations as well as the benefits
ultimately of Germany yesterday the eu's
oil price caps kicked in how effective
do you think can they be at limiting
Revenue Russia can use to finance the
war
so you ask the question can they be so
I'm going to start by answering in
general terms I think in general price
gaps can be very effective
um for two reasons first price caps are
a mechanism to reduce revenues to Russia
without
um abruptly reducing supply to the
market so unlike an outright embargo
price caps are still allowing that
wealth to flow but are reducing the
amount of money that is paid to Russia
for that oil as long as they're above
the production costs there is an
economic incentive for Russia to
continue
um producing rather than shutting down
and harming the energy producing
infrastructure as a result and the
second reason is that it broadens the
set of countries that are cooperating so
in terms of the Embargo that's kind of
would be used as an embargo that's a
certain set of countries that are not
buying Russian oil with a price cap
we're actually pulling in other
potential Partners in this endeavor the
countries that are relying on shipping
companies and insurance companies and
that are going to conform with the price
Gap as a result so kind of a broader set
of countries that are effectively
participating in the sanctioning that's
in general if we talk about specifics
then that of course depends on the level
of the price cap and how much that
actually is going to reduce Russia's
revenues
what else needs to be done in the way of
international sanctions to get leverage
over the Kremlin I did want to ask you
that we don't have much time though
yeah
um so of course with the sanctions that
are already in place there's always room
for improvement so we just talked about
price caps it's a great start to have a
price Gap at sixty dollars it's not
going to do that much so we definitely
hopefully will be working towards
lowering that limit in the future our
group of experts recommend somewhere
around 35
but more broadly there's still a lot of
um leverage that the Western countries
have we said use the Russian economy
that we still haven't really exploited I
think the main area going forward is
going to be technology sanctions
um so Western technology still permeates
Russian Society we see these pictures of
LA brov with his iPhone
um and that's that's a single case but
in in reality Russia is using Western
phones Western software all of that to
both
um do the military actions as well as to
prop up the economy so
um limiting that limiting the Western
technology will have a big impact on the
Russian economy in general anesthetic of
use see Berkeley thank you so much for
your time
thank you